all right but we're gonna begin with
this only on CBS this morning we have an
exclusive look at the testing of what
could become the world's first air taxi
without a pilot the airbus prototype is
meant to operate like a flying
self-driving car and it's being tested
at a rural Airport in Oregon Kris Van
Cleave got a sneak peek at what could be
the future of ride-sharing this airport
is a special zone for testing unmanned
aircraft and the one behind me is pretty
special it has the potential to change
the way people move Airbus calls it
vahana it is a prototype of an
autonomous air taxi think of it as a bit
of a flying car and test all 101 is she
take off on my mark 3 in San Script
vahana means that which carries that
which pulls in Oregon Mohandas 8
electric motors hope to carry the future
there's no human at the controls of this
prototype single-seat autonomous air
taxi as it takes off vertically like a
helicopter its wings then rotate
allowing it to fly like a plane the
battery powered aircraft hit speeds over
a hundred miles an hour and can fly up
to 35 miles per veja lair is the project
manager for vahana do you think you're
gonna get people who want to get in a
flying contraption that doesn't have a
pilot over time people will get used to
its buzzing over rural Oregon this could
be the answer to our been gridlock
simply flying over the traffic jam but
convincing the public might be a
challenge even among those 18 to 24 only
about one in five say they fly in
something without a pilot how do you
convince people to change their mind I
mean at some point you need some first
adopters to go all right I'm getting at
it you want to demonstrate perfect
safety and you know real added value for
the customer and you know this is really
about saving time in a convenient and
safe way plane maker air buses Silicon
Valley incubator a cubed took vahana
from a sketch to flight testing in less
than two years using materials already
commercially available we've been
working on showing that we can execute a
safe test flight from takeoff through
transition to over 100 miles an hour and
return safely to the ground right now
the test flights aren't very long they
only last a few minutes at a time
one of the challenges will be developing
better lighter batteries that let these
things fly farther and longer Morgan
Stanley predicts flying cars will be a
one point five to three trillion dollar
business in 20 years the race is on now
to develop a fleet of ride-sharing
autonomous air taxis think flying
goobers
earlier this year Boeing's prototype
took its first flight at this month's
uber elevate conference nearly a dozen
flying car concepts were on display
including helicopter maker bells
full-size but non flying Nexus
demonstrator it seats four passengers
and aims to enter customer service by
the mid-2020s flying at 150 miles an
hour for up to 150 miles for a time it
will have a human operator on board
before going fully autonomous a lot of
us grew up watching the Jetsons and
thought that was far-fetched the reality
is here today when you look at the
explosion and expansion of population
growth within cities there really no
ground-based solutions that we'll be
able to resolve those challenges well
we're not ready today
acting FAA Administrator Dan Elwell says
it's too early to talk about timelines
we're all about gathering data to assure
us of the of the safety for these
vehicles and unmanned is a much much
higher bar than a piloted vehicle for
sure and we we have a ways to go
regulations and a system to manage
increasingly crowded airspace still
needs to be developed for Airbus vahana
is a bit like a first draft it'll be up
to future models to prove they can
safely fly passengers it will be years
before people are flying in an
autonomous air taxi but already a
company in London is buying up rooftop
space for landing pads so they'll be
ready when the technology is set to take
off for CBS this morning Kris Van Cleave
Pendleton Oregon Yale no where does one
buy a pair of depends I like the idea of
it I do I like the idea of it I could
see it working I'm just very afraid but
I could see how this could work and that
people would get on board but you you
wouldn't take the driverless car to get
I need to get on board Andy I do I know
I need to do I know I know
let's start with a piloted aircraft well
I think we will yeah but those old jets
and clips are getting a lot of play
these days that's for sure what they're
doing yeah